hello and welcome back to reality check
and to the second episode of our
three-part reality check special all
about the science of upcoming sci-fi
thriller prey last week we upgraded our
puny human brains with mods your mods to
be precise make sure you get that
episode direct into your eyeballs if you
haven't already this week we're going to
delve into the science of one of the
coolest and most useful pieces of future
tech found aboard the space station
Talos 1 a fabricator it's basically the
ultimate in video game crafting require
a glue canister for your glue cannon not
a problem
need a new mug because your old one
transformed into an alien sure thing
buddy leaving you face because the mug
alienate your face oh my god so how does
it work well before you can make stuff
you need to have all the various
building blocks required these can be
obtained by cramming all of the junk you
find around Tallis 1 into another
machine called the recycler in essence
this combo of recycler and fabricator
allows you to craft almost anything from
the trash you find around the station
not only is this really cool and useful
it's also highly ethical so how close
are we to getting when these fabricators
in real life well to help me out
I asked nanomaterials chemist dr. Seuss
candy
the fabricator we see in prey is pretty
advanced we're not quite there yet but
3d printing has taken us pretty far
already not only are we able to print in
a range of different materials 3d
printers are a lot cheaper these days
and we can create far more intricate
things than we could before
recently a 3d printer was released where
you can print in two different materials
one of which can be a dissolvable
substance now it prints is a solid
material but as soon as you've created
something you wouldn't otherwise be able
to create without the support you can
pop it into a tank of water and one of
those materials will dissolve away
leaving something you just wouldn't
otherwise be able to have created before
in fact the very latest 3d printers now
alive for up to thirteen materials to be
printed simultaneously other
cutting-edge uses of 3d printing include
super tough ceramics prosthetic limbs
video game weapon replicas bridges
entire houses and even people kind of
you can even create tissue these days so
by 3d printing a bio scaffold you're
able to inject that with somebody stem
cells and encourage those stem cells to
grow into different bits of tissue that
can be transplanted into the body so 3d
printing is not just spare parts be a
washing machine could be spare parts for
humans as well
[Music]
as exciting as modern 3d printing is
though it's not quite up there with the
fabricator
first off 3d printing is much much
slower than it pales in comparison and
what you can create in terms of
materials and complexity however as is
often the case in science these days the
answer might be to approach from a
different scale that's right we need to
go nano nano fabrication is building
from the atomic level all the way up to
create actual materials so by arranging
different atoms we can create molecules
by ranging those molecules together we
can create a range of different
materials so I imagine that there's a
nano fabricator would have a VAT
containing all of the elements they
could be siloed up so that you have each
of these elements available to you as
you wish
perhaps in these different little
siphons and this nano fabricator could
potentially take any absence it needed
and put it in exactly the right place to
create any material that you want this
notion of a nano fabricator is not a new
idea though back in 2013 when talking to
the BBC science historian and all-round
cool guy James Burke predicted a future
when all people have their own personal
nano factories using these machines
Burke predicts that individuals would be
able to print pretty much anything they
could ever want from just the stuff
around them dirt and water after all
these two things contains a lot of the
basic elements that you would need
although perhaps not everything there'd
be certain elements that you wouldn't be
able to get hold of in just the stuff
around you so some of those rarer
elements you could probably crush up a
mobile phone actually and release a fair
few of the ones that you were missing so
what is holding us back from actually
creating Nano fabricators today nano
technologies biggest challenge at the
moment is that when you scale things up
you lose efficiency and you lose some of
the potential for that nano technology
to work when you think about building
something if we were to build on an
atomic scale we are just simply
way too big to do it we are actual
Giants in the Nano world and this is why
we need to create things that are much
smaller to be able to do that for us so
if we want to create something that can
build on an atomic scale we need to push
that science and engineering even
further so that we can create even
tinier machines that are actually able
to do that that can work on that atomic
scale so if I understand this right we
need to figure out how to build tiny
robots so they can build tiny robots so
we can build anything we like like a
giant robot well if we can solve this
particular problem of scale perhaps
there will be a fabricator of sorts in
our future let me know the first thing
you would fabricate if you had one in
the comments down below
now come back next week for the final of
our three-part reality check special
episode 3 is all about the psychology of
being pray don't miss it
[Music]